[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit hanna
zimmermann und christian sievers
hallo und guten abend hinein wir nehmen
sie am beginn dieses heute journals mit
auf eine reise durch ein land das gerade
luft holt weil es im kampf gegen einen
vermeintlich übermächtigen gegner stand
gehalten hat es ist aber auch ein land
dem der atem stockt weil dort wo sich
dieser gegner zurückzog fürchterliche
greuel ans tageslicht kommen wer exakt
dahinter steckt muss jetzt dringend
geklärt werden unser reporter tim kröger
war heute unterwegs aus der hafenstadt
odessa am schwarzen meer auf einer
strategisch wichtigen route in die stadt
nikolajew hier ist seine reportage
die straße m14 zwischen der
hafenmetropole odessa und der stadt mit
go live material für barrikaden immer
wieder mit go live ist der letzte
grössere vorposten vor odessa und darf
deshalb nicht zahlen die situation ist
nicht so schlimm wie etwa in mario pohl
und doch sind auch die menschen in
nikolajew dem täglichen wahnsinn dieses
krieges ausgesetzt gestern am hellichten
tag schlug in einer ladenstraße ein
geschoss ein acht menschen sollen
gestorben sein die überlebenden sind
auch am tag danach noch völlig
schockiert
ich habe angst jedes geräusch macht mir
zu schaffen zuvor waren die bomben nicht
so schlimm jetzt ist es fürchterlich und
dann legt er diese frau mit ihrem
gesicht
terror gegen die zivilbevölkerung
seit dem wochenende schlagen mehrmals
täglich raketen ein luftalarm schreckt
die menschen immer wieder auf der
bürgermeister trägt eine waffe weil
ukrainische stadtoberhäupter von
russischen truppen schon öfter
verschleppt wurden mitunter seien es
streubomben mit denen die menschen
angegriffen werden sagte er euro wo
diese menschen waren zivilisten die
russischen truppen benutzten streubomben
sie schießen sie aus der richtung der
stadt herten ab in drei minuten sind sie
da die explodieren am himmel und fallen
dann in kleinen teilen in einem großen
radius herunter
viele menschen in der stadt und den
umliegenden dörfern wollen weg in den
westen der ukraine oder weiter nach
polen am sammelpunkt für die evakuierung
fließen die tränen angehörige bleiben
zurück
dieser platte ist einfach zu gefährlich
geworden wir haben ein kind und bringen
es weg von hier an einen platz an dem es
ruhig und friedlich ist wo es keine
raketenangriffe kein töten gibt wie hier
wir fahren noch etwas weiter raus aus
der stadt richtung front etliche
kilometer südlich wird noch gekämpft bis
dorthin wurden die russischen boden
truppen zurückgedrängt wir treffen auf
checkpoints panzer und helikopter die
wir aber aus sicherheitsgründen nicht
zeigen dürfen die dörfer größtenteils
verlassen und niemand weiß wann die
menschen zurückkehren werden
und das hier sind bilder aus butscher es
war mal einer der lebenswertesten
vororte von kiew wo junge familien sich
ein häuschen kauften im grünen außerhalb
der region war der name der stadt kaum
jemanden ein begriff jetzt kennt ihn die
ganze welt und auf längere zeit wird das
leben dorthin nicht zurückkehren können
butscher steht für tot für grausame
bilder leichen in den straßen was genau
ist dort passiert katrin eigendorf war
auf spurensuche
eine improvisierte küche im hof ein paar
habseligkeiten die sie retten konnten zu
leben die einwohner der
plattenbausiedlung am rande von butscher
viele wohnungen zerstört es gibt weder
wasser noch strom
und doch sind sie geblieben denn viele
wissen gar nicht wohin und wie überhaupt
den ort verlassen auf der straße warten
einige menschen auf eine
lebensmittelausgabe wir fragen was sie
erlebt haben in den vier wochen in denen
die russische armee buscher besetzt
hatte
es wurden viele erschossen hier wurde
einer meiner bekannten erschossen er war
mit seinem sohn vor dem laden hier der
wurde in die schulter getroffen und
verletzt mein bekannten haben sie da
drüben im hof begraben
[Musik]
mein freund ist aus dem haus gegangen
sie haben ihn in den kopf geschossen
seiner frau haben die soldaten gesagt
bis zum morgen dürfen sie nicht aus dem
haus als sie herauskam hat sie in der
tod liegen sehen auch an diesem morgen
bergen freiwillige die toten noch immer
finden sie laichen in den häusern noch
ist nicht klar wie viele menschen
tatsächlich in butter ums leben kamen
doch immer mehr bezeugen wie die
russischen soldaten in dem ort vorgingen
sie gehen rein wenn ihnen ein haus
gefällt erschießen alle sie schmeißen
die leichen raus verbrennen sie und dann
übernachten sie dort unter kohl
auf der rax einer straße sind
journalistinnen aus aller welt um zu
dokumentieren was passiert ist dimitrow
sein haus direkt an der völlig
zerstörten straße in der noch bis vor
kurzem überall leichen lagen erzählt er
einen haben meinen nachbarn erkannt dass
war unser gemeinsamer nachbar er wurde
schon weg gebracht er hat lange zwischen
den häusern hier gelegen und da waren
die leichen anderer männer ich habe sie
mir nicht angeschaut sie waren schon
schwarz
dass russland behauptet alles was sie
hier in butter erlebt haben sei eine
inszenierung
schmerzt macht wütend es bleibt nur die
hoffnung dass die welt die wahrheit
erfährt über das was wirklich geschah in
butter
ja wenn einer sagt die erde ist eine
kugel und der andere nein die erde ist
eine scheibe kann man diese diskussion
dann zusammenfassen in der ausgewogenen
schlagzeile streit um die form der erde
wohl kaum so ähnlich ist es heute im
ehrwürdigen saal des weltsicherheitsrats
der vereinten nationen die eine seite
klagt an verweist auf viele tote in den
straßen der gegend die bis vor kurzem
noch von russland besetzt war auf
massengräber auf kaum zu ertragendes
drohungen der lokalen bewohner wir haben
sie gerade gesehen und auf
satellitenaufnahmen aus dem all
russland sagt lapidar alles lügen wir
haben damit nichts zu tun johannes hano
jetzt über eine denkwürdige sitzung in
new york und ein hinweis für sie der
beitrag zeigt drastische bilder
es war eine sitzung die in die
geschichte des un-sicherheitsrates
eingehen wird wie den anfang einer
großen umwälzung dieser weltorganisation
bedeuten könnte die britische
ratspräsidentschaft hatte den
präsidenten der ukraine lowinski
eingeladen auch um der erwartbaren
russischen version zu den brutalen
kriegsverbrechen in butter gleich zu
beginn etwas entgegenzusetzen und man
spürte incidents stimme tiefe
traurigkeit und wut
es gibt kein verbrechen das sie nicht
mehr gehen würden das russische militär
hat nach allen gesucht die unserem land
dienen um sie umzubringen sie
unterscheiden sich nicht von anderen
terroristen wie dem erst zum beispiel
wenn der orte einnimmt nur dass es sich
hier von um ein mitglied des
un-sicherheitsrates handelt
zielinski präsentierte der welt bilder
von folter und bestialischen mord die
nur schwer zu ertragen waren und die so
manchem die tränen in die augen trieb
und dann ging der ukrainische präsident
mit den vereinten nationen und ganz
besonders dem un sicherheitsrat scharf
ins gericht
es ist offensichtlich dass die zentrale
institution der welt deren aufgabe es
ist den frieden zu erzwingen seine
arbeit nicht macht
wir haben jetzt hier mit einem staat zu
tun der das veto im un-sicherheitsrat
das recht zu töten umwandelt das
untergräbt die gesamte
sicherheitsarchitektur unserer welt wenn
wir ihnen erlauben so weiterzumachen
wenn der sicherheitsrat sich nicht
reformieren würde um seinen aufgaben
nachzukommen dann bräuchte man ihn nicht
mehr so zielinski wie zu erwarten
reagierte der russische un-botschafter
scharf russland sei in der ukraine um
frieden zu bringen und um das land von
den nazis zu befreien die hinter allem
stecken und dann präsentierte er die
russische version der gold daten in
butter die längst widerlegt und von den
meisten mitgliedern des sicherheitsrates
als absurde lüge bezeichnet wurden
wir sehen die kriminelle inszenierungen
rheinischer zivilisten die von radikalen
getötet wurden um in bester goebbels
manier die russische armee zu
beschuldigen
beweise für seine behauptung aber blieb
er wie so oft in den vergangenen wochen
schuldig eines ist heute endgültig klar
geworden und der ukrainische präsident
hat es auf den punkt gebracht so lange
putins russland mit am tisch sitzt ist
der un-sicherheitsrat handlungsunfähig
und reformen rutscht der endgültig in
die bedeutungslosigkeit
die eu will zum ersten mal mit ihren
sanktionen jetzt auch den lukrativen
energiesektor russlands ins visier
nehmen und schlägt ein importverbot für
kohle aus russland vor vier milliarden
euro zahlt europa dafür jedes jahr
bislang wenn das stoppt hat das folgen
für russland aber auch für uns in
deutschland das dürfte ein wichtiges
thema seien im sicherheitskabinett der
bundesregierung das jetzt im moment tagt
am ende eines langen tages in berlin
andreas künast
wer ist denn heute in berlin fragen die
berliner und es gibt eine lange antwort
die schweiz norwegen bulgarien kanada
polen und 25 weitere und eine kurze
antwort der westen
auf einladung von deutschland frankreich
und rumänien versammeln sich 30 staaten
im auswärtigen amt 30 für einen für das
nachbarland der ukraine das relativ die
meisten flüchtlinge aufnimmt und absolut
die größte angst hat auch moldau hat
eine pro-russische separatisten region
auch dort steht moskaus militär diese
konferenz heute ist auch eine deutliche
botschaft
kein land ist verfügungsmasse niemand
ist russlands hinterhof über die
notwendigkeit moldau zu helfen sind sich
europa und gäste schnell einig aber vor
allem die osteuropäer wollen unbedingt
noch über ein anderes land reden über
deutschland das ist nicht zeit für
passivität für egoismus dass es zeit für
mode und gerade entscheidungen darüber
heute werde ich auch hier sprechen der
druck auf die bundesregierung wächst
aber ihre entscheidungen werden größer
die außenministerin weist gestern 40
russische diplomaten aus die
verteidigungsministerin stellt weitere
waffenlieferungen in aussicht und der
wirtschaftsminister stimmt erstmals
sanktionen im energie bereich zu es
beginnt mit der kohle insofern war immer
die maßgabe dass wir im herbst frei von
russischer kohle sein können wir werden
das mit der eu kommission darüber reden
wie sie das ganze sich in einem
sanktionspaket wieder finden kann und
was die anderen partnern dazu sagen die
chefs von bundesnachrichtendienst und
verfassungsschutz informieren am abend
die zuständigen minister was kann
deutschland noch tun und wie reagiert
russland erst gestern hat die
bundesregierung eine gazprom-tochter
unter aufsicht gestellt wie es heißt
streng nach deutschem recht trotzdem
droht heute der kreml mit vergeltung
wir hören offizielle erklärungen über
die mögliche verstaatlichung unserer
vermögenswerte ich hoffe dass niemand
vergisst dass das eine zweischneidige
waffe wäre
beim erdgas bei gazprom landet fast jede
sanktions debatte bei fehlern die jetzt
auch fehler genannt werden das ist eine
bittere bilanz vor der wir stehen und zu
dieser bitteren bilanz gehört auch die
fehleinschätzung dass wir und auch ich
gedacht haben
dass auch ein putin des jahres 2022 am
ende nicht den totalen
politischen wirtschaftlichen moralischen
ruin hinnehmen würde für seinen imperial
war für moldau kommen an diesem tag fast
700 millionen euro zusammen der umgang
mit russland hat die staatengemeinschaft
über jahre gespalten heute weist er den
westen zusammen
christoph heusgen war lange jahre der
wichtigste außenpolitische berater von
bundeskanzlerin angela merkel
für alle denen das nichts sagt nur eine
kleine szene
hier verabschiedet sich barack obama von
merkel und steigt dann extra noch mal
aus weil er vergessen hatte auch
häuschen die hand zu geben
tschüss christoph hat er da gerade noch
gesagt glaube ich wir sagen jetzt guten
abend an den vorsitzenden der münchner
sicherheitskonferenz am kiosk intensiver
gucken wir erst mal einen moment zurück
bitte der bundespräsident hat jetzt
praktisch das komplette scheitern seiner
russlandpolitik in seiner zeit als
außenminister eingeräumt auch er habe
sich geirrt partner seien nicht gehört
worden würden sie das auch über sich
selbst sagen und die politik von angela
merkel
wir sehen heute dass putin sehr viel
weitergegangen ist als wir gedacht haben
ich muss ihnen ganz ehrlich sagen noch
am ende der münchner
sicherheitskonferenz vier tage vor dem
einmarsch russlands in die ukraine war
ich angesichts auch des großen
einvernehmens was in münchen herrscht
hat der meinung putin wird nicht
einmarschieren er ist einmarschiert und
er hat damit das völkerrecht massiv
gebrochen und er hat alles das was über
jahre jahrzehnte versucht worden ist mit
russland aufzubauen zunichte gemacht
jetzt ist es natürlich so dass man
hinterher immer schlauer ist manche muss
man aber sagen waren es vielleicht auch
vorher schon wenn man allein liest was
die russische journalistin anna
politkowskaja geschrieben hat 2006 hat
sie geschrieben putin präsident und
diktator und praktisch alles vorher
gesagt was jetzt eingetreten ist sie ist
danach in moskau ermordet worden das
haben sie doch auch gelesen herausgehen
natürlich wir haben das gelesen wir
haben auch gesehen wie
kritisch das mit russland ist wir haben
immer versucht aber mit russland in
kontakt zu bleiben auch immer wieder zu
versuchen
russland einzuhegen wir haben ja dann
nach der invasion
2014 nach in die ukraine als sie die
krim besetzt haben und den don was in
harten verhandlungen dazu gehört dass er
dass er aufgehört hat mit dem vormarsch
seinerzeit wir haben dann versucht den
harten verhandlungen auch ihn ein zu dem
was wäre die alternative gewesen ich
glaube es war immer wichtig mit russland
zu sprechen was jetzt passiert ist hat
allerdings alle dimensionen gesprengt
und ich glaube es hat sehr viel auch
damit zu tun dass putin den letzten zwei
jahren isoliert war er hat nicht mehr
mit der außenwelt gesprochen er hat sich
seine eigenen fantasien über die kleine
hatte sich zu eigen gemacht und daran
geglaubt und das war etwas was sehr
dramatisch war was ich vor vielen jahren
so in dieser dramatik nicht abgezeichnet
hat das klingt jetzt ein bisschen so als
beruhe die internationale außenpolitik
vor allem auf dem prinzip hoffnung auch
wenn dann die fakten sich doch ein
bisschen anders darstellen oder war es
vielleicht am ende zum beispiel die
günstige preiswerte energielieferung aus
russland nach deutschland
gut die frage wieweit macht man sich
abhängig von einem anderen land ist
absolut wichtig es galt über jahre
jahrzehnte seit beginn der
bundesrepublik des dass worte handel
durch wandel den versuch mit russland
auch durch eine aufbau eines dialogs es
gab den sogenannten petersburger dialog
wo man zivilgesellschaft wirtschaft
politik miteinander geredet hat das war
richtig dass wir das gemacht haben
man darf aber und da haben sie absolut
recht das gilt eben auch im hinblick auf
china man darf sich nicht zu sehr
abhängig machen von einem in diesem fall
handelspartner wie russland sie waren
gegen nord stream 2 kann man zumindest
lesen hat auch sie niemand gehört auch
die bundeskanzlerin nicht
wissen sie es ist so wir sind in einer
koalition gewesen 2015 in einer
koalition mit den sozialdemokraten wo es
darum ging sollen wir nord stream 2 nun
auch nachts um eins machen oder nicht
und da spielen dann außenpolitische
dinge rein das spielen
wirtschaftspolitische dinge rein und im
ergebnis wer wird das dann miteinander
abgewogen und dem ergebnis war es so
dass dann entschieden worden ist wir
sehen das als ein kommerzielles projekt
an und wenn es mit eu recht vereinbar
ist dann wird es
durchgezogen ist interessant dass ich
jetzt sagen da spielen viele politische
aspekte rein außenpolitisch
wirtschaftspolitische argumente sagte
man hören und das hat ja auch angela
merkel lange zeit gesagt es ist ein rein
privatwirtschaftliches projekt hat mit
politik eigentlich gar nichts zu tun
herr ausgehen lassen sie uns jetzt an
der steller vielleicht mal nach vorne
gucken ist dennoch denkbar mit wladimir
putin jemals wieder an einem tisch zu
sitzen zum beispiel beim nächsten g20
gipfel der es im herbst in indonesien
ich halte es für schwer vorstellbar dass
man mit tut ihnen noch mal um einen
tisch sitzt das ist jemand der alles
internationale recht gebrochen hat was
es zu brechen geht auf ihn kann man sich
nicht verlassen man kann
das papier auf den auf den seiner
unterschrift steht kann man ist es nicht
wert es ist sehr schwierig sich
vorzustellen
putin hat alle glaubwürdigkeit verloren
er hat begibt begeht kriegsverbrechen
aus meiner sicht gehört es eben auch
nachdem auch was man gesehen hat was die
russischen streitkräfte im auftrag
putins machen er gehört sowie milosevic
vor einen internationalen gerichtshof
sie waren als deutsche uno-botschafter
auch turnusgemäß immer wieder
vorsitzender des uno-sicherheitsrats
wenn sie sehen was da jetzt auch heute
gerade wieder vor sich geht russland
streitet alles ab sagt das sind einfach
alles lügen auf der anderen seite hat
russland ein vetorecht wie viel wert ist
das gremium noch
ja das ist es ist ganz ganz schwierig
ich habe das auch als vorsitzender
sicherheitsrates erlebt als russland
humanitäre hilfe
die nach syrien gehen sollte zusammen
mit china wo sie ein veto eingelegt
haben das war ein ganz harte situationen
es ist eine grundbedingung des
sicherheitsrates nur so haben die usa
china und russland seinerzeit zugestimmt
einem sicherheitsrat dass sie ein veto
haben es gibt fragen da kommen sie nicht
weiter aber es gibt viele andere fragen
wo sie im sicherheitsrat wo sie bei den
vereinten nationen weiter kommen also
dieses gremium aufgeben dürfen wir auf
keinen fall sagt christoph heusgen
vorsitzender der münchner
sicherheitskonferenz vielen dank für das
gespräch
gerne
und das gespräch haben wir kurz vor
dieser sendung aufgezeichnet aus
termingründen so hanna hat jetzt
gebündelt weitere wichtige nachrichten
von heute als erstes land in der eu muss
sich ungarn einem verfahren wegen
möglicher verstöße gegen die
rechtsstaatlichkeit stellen das hat
kommissionspräsidentin von der leyen
bekannt gegeben konkret geht es um den
vorwurf der korruption der jetzt
aktivierte rechtsstaat mechanismus
ermöglicht auch die kürzung von eu
geldern
zunächst hat budapest allerdings die
möglichkeit zu den vorwürfen stellung zu
beziehen
deutsche ermittler haben den weltweit
größten illegalen marktplatz im darknet
hydra market abgeschaltet wie das
bundeskriminalamt mitteilte wurden
server beschlagnahmt und bitcoins im
wert von 23 millionen euro gesichert auf
hydra market sei unter anderem mit
drogen und gefälschten dokumenten
gehandelt worden das bka hat heute auch
die aktuelle kriminalstatistik
vorgestellt demnach haben sich
cybercrime delikte seit 2015 verdoppelt
insgesamt seien die polizeilich
erfassten straftaten aber vergangenes
jahr erneut gesunken um 4,9 prozent
im ringen um eine mögliche impfpflicht
in deutschland gibt es einen neuen
kompromissvorschlag zwei abgeordneten
gruppen die bisher jeweils eigene
entwürfe dafür eingebracht hatten haben
sich auf einen gemeinsamen vorschlag
geeinigt dieser sieht ab oktober eine
impfpflicht für menschen ab 60 vor und
die möglichkeit diese im herbst auch
noch per bundestagsbeschluss auf jüngere
auszuweiten orientiert am jeweiligen
infektionsgeschehen
ab dem ersten mai ist die
isolationsschicht in deutschland für die
meisten bürgerinnen und bürger
geschichte dann gilt das prinzip der
freiwilligkeit und das stößt auf kritik
die deutsche stiftung patientenschutz
und der sozialverband vdk verwiesen auf
die gefahren für risikogruppen ältere
chronisch kranke oder menschen mit
behinderungen und auch aus der
opposition kommt kritik
linken-fraktionschefin mohammed ali
warnte vor konsequenzen für menschen in
unsicheren beschäftigungsverhältnissen
die bei einer infektion eine
krankschreibung scheuen könnten
in deutschlands krankenhäusern wurden
2021 deutlich weniger patienten
behandelt als vor der korona pandemie
dort dem krankenhaus report des
wissenschaftlichen instituts der aok lag
der rückgang bei 14 prozent im vergleich
zum jahr 2019 und auch für dieses jahr
wird mit einem einbruch der
patientenzahlen gerechnet hauptgrund
seien personalengpässe in folge von
corona infektionen diese würden zu
absagen von behandlungen und operationen
führen
so sieht shanghai aus quirlige
megalopolis eine der größten städte der
erde
drehscheibe des handels mit dem umschlag
stärksten containerhafen der welt
wirtschaftsmotor schaltstelle für die
globalen lieferketten all das steht
gerade auf dem spiel denn 26 millionen
menschen in shanghai sind im
drakonischen lockdown mit dem die
zentralregierung kämpfen will gegen die
schlimmste corona welle dort seit zwei
jahren es spielen sich unfassbare szenen
ab eigentlich sollte der lockdown heute
zu ende gehen er wurde verlängert auf
unbestimmte zeit wulff war
shanghai gleicht einer geisterstadt
niemand darf seine wohnung verlassen das
corona virus hat die 26 millionen
metropole fest im griff ärzte und
pfleger aus dem ganzen land werden nach
shanghai geschickt wir werden erfolg
haben schreiben sie sie sollen helfen
alle einwohner zu testen die
hochansteckende omikron variante bringt
chinas 0 kowitz strategie an ihre
grenzen
das omikron virus bedroht die gesundheit
vor allem von älteren und kindern wir
müssen deshalb die infektions ausbrüche
unter kontrolle halten
die behörden greifen zu drastischen
maßnahmen infizierte babys und
kleinkinder werden teilweise zwangsweise
von ihren eltern getrennt laut
augenzeugen sollen zehn
krankenschwestern auf 200 kinder
aufpassen und keine zeit haben die
windeln zu wechseln
ein vater schreibt die chinesischen
medienberichten nicht was hier passiert
sie bricht nur positives die offizielle
propaganda zeigt ein perfekt
funktionierendes system in dem familien
gut betreut werden auch die
lebensmittelversorgung soll reibungslos
laufen in den chinesischen sozialen
medien gibt es allerdings viel unmut
ich verhungere keiner hilft wird die
frau
der omicron ausbruch hat chinas führung
kalt erwischt sie haben die
ansteckungsgefahr unterschätzt jetzt
werden mobile krankenhäuser aus dem
boden gestampft messehallen zu riesigen
betten lagern umfunktioniert roboter
kommen zum einsatz liefern medizinisches
gerät an doch bilder im netz zeigen wie
notdürftig diese unterkünfte sind wie
eng die menschen zusammen liegen müssen
viele können nicht zum krankenhaus gehen
weil die behörden sie nicht aus der
quarantäne rauslassen hilferufe aus dem
fenster
er ist gestorben schreibt die frau
er hätte ins gartenhaus gewusst aber
niemand hat uns geholfen
chinas führung setzt nun verstärkt auf
impfungen inoffizielle zahlen gehen
davon aus dass 130 millionen ältere
nicht ausreichenden impfschutz haben der
kampf gegen das virus in china beginnt
jetzt erst richtig ernst zu werden
unfassbare bilder kinder und babys die
von ihren eltern getrennt werden die
strategie führt selbst in china zu
protesten wenn man das überhaupt
strategie nennen kann
hanna macht hier nochmal weiter mit
weiteren nachrichten und kommt bisschen
zurück zu am anfang der sendung ganz
genau wir wollen noch mal genauer auf
die möglichen folgen eines kohle
importstopps für deutschland schauen
sagt dass nämlich bisher kam etwa 50
prozent unserer steinkohle aus russland
und bundeswirtschaftsminister harbeck
hat eigentlich erst den herbst angepeilt
um frei von russischer steinkohle zu
sein das hat auch heute noch mal betont
fragen wir nach bei valerie haller in
frankfurt was wir das denn bedeuten wenn
es jetzt schneller gehen müsste also ein
sofortiger importstopp käme ja also
spontan das wäre wohl eher schwierig die
reserven reichen nämlich nur bis zu
sechs wochen ja und wenn die
aufgebraucht sind dann müssten wohl
einzelne kraftwerke abgeschaltet werden
verbunden vermutlich mit engpässen für
die industrie aber wenn deutschland auf
eine russische energiequelle verzichten
dann noch am ehesten auf die steinkohle
denn die gibt es wenn auch nicht billig
woanders zuhauf in kolumbien südafrika
australien zum beispiel die hälfte der
russischen kohle wird in
kohlekraftwerken
verfeuert der rest ist für die
stahlproduktion zu beginn des krieges
kam noch die hälfte der importkohle aus
russland in wenigen wochen sollen es 25
prozent weniger sein im herbst dann
kommt deutschland komplett ohne
russische kohle aus meint zumindest das
wirtschaftsministerium schon jetzt
spielt steinkohle im vergleich zu
anderen energieträgern keine besonders
große rolle gerade mal 8,6 prozent
machte sie vergangenes jahr aus erdgas
hingegen fast 27 prozent
steinkohle ist für deutschland also noch
die am ehesten verzichtbare
energiequelle geringe bedeutung im
energiemix aber eine botschaft an moskau
ist es dennoch die einst selbst
geschaffene abhängigkeit wird nun
schritt für schritt wieder aufgelöst
vielen dank valerie
auf die über 14 millionen kunden des
energieversorgers eon könnten demnächst
deutliche preissteigerungen bei gas und
strom zu kommen das sagte eon-chef ton
dem redaktions netzwerk deutschland die
preise im großhandel für erdgas würden
im vergleich zum frühjahr 2020 zum teil
um das 20 fache höher liegen bei strom
um das achtfache
verbraucherschützer warnen die
erhöhungen würden erst im nächsten jahr
mit der nebenkostenabrechnung in den
haushalten ankommen
bei den tarifverhandlungen für die
chemie und pharmaindustrie haben sich
arbeitgeber und gewerkschaften auf einen
teil abschluss geeinigt die bundesweit
etwa 580.000 beschäftigten sollen eine
einmalzahlung von 1400 euro pro
arbeitnehmer erhalten wegen des ukraine
kriegs und der stark gestiegenen
energiepreise sehen beide seiten darin
eine übergangslösung im oktober sollen
die tarifverhandlungen fortgesetzt
werden
sogar die abgelegene arktis ist voll von
plastikmüll das ausmaß zeigt nun eine
neue studie unter beteiligung des
alfred-wegener-instituts die
konzentration an klassik in der arktis
sei mittlerweile
ähnlich hoch wie in dicht besiedelten
regionen erklären die forscher ein
großteil werde durch mehrere ströme aus
anderen teilen der welt in die arktis
transportiert aber auch entsorgte
fischernetze würden massiv zur
problematik beitragen
kein tag für gute nachrichten das war
die welt an diesem dienstag von uns
allen hier danke dass sie dabei waren
und gegen 0.20 gibt's dann unser
heute-journal update mit nazan charakter
mir ihnen einen angenehmen abend
[Musik]
guten abend kaum ist das eine tiefe nach
osten abgezogen kommt das nächste schon
gleich hinterher und so droht am
donnerstag sturm der wind nimmt aber
schon morgen zu und deswegen nehmen wir
uns mal die böen mit 62 kilometer pro
stunde und mehr vor da sehen sie nämlich
wie dieses windfeld ganz deutschland
überstreift der höhepunkt wird am
donnerstag erreicht es gibt sogar
orkanböen windgeschwindigkeiten von über
100 kilometer pro stunde jetzt in der
nacht fällt häufig regen im südwesten
ist dagegen auch trocken und meist wird
das eine milde nacht mit
tiefsttemperaturen von 9 bis 5 grad
kälter ist es nur in der ostsee oder
auch am alpenrand mit zwei oder drei
grad morgen liegen die temperaturen in
nordfriesland bei neun grad sonst gibt
es zweistellige werte zwischen zehn und
16 oder gar 17 gerade oder mildesten
wird es in der lausitz und an der donau
genau dort wo sich morgen auch am
häufigsten die sonne zeigt in
norddeutschland ist es dagegen bedeckt
und vor allen dingen vormittags kann es
auch noch kräftiger regnen nachmittags
kommen von westen einige regenschauer
heran und dann kommt das sturmtief am
donnerstag es bin schnee regen und
graupelschauer mit auch gewitter sind
dabei bei 8 bis 16 grad am freitag
drohte an intensiver dauerregen im
südwesten bei 6 bis 14 grad und der
samstag wird dann deutlich kälter mit
fünf bis elf grad aber das bleibt nicht
so wie sie hier am trend für freiburg
gemeinsam sehen können wird es in der
karwoche doch temperaturen zum teil über
20 grad geben guten abend